avec nos plateaux Cyril païen bonjour
cyril volody mercedilenski est en route
il survolerait théoriquement
l'Atlantique pour arriver à Washington
on imagine que les conditions de
sécurité sont drastiques c'est un voyage
à haut risque qui a une portée
symbolique et sécuritaire complètement
incroyable et c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
là où le président ukrainien joue le son
destin le destin de l'Ukraine et
peut-être même le destin de cette guerre
qui est rentrée dans son dans son 300e
jour on le sait donc c'était pas
certainement un hasard mais oui autre
sécurité on le sait avec de la rédaction
de France 24 on a pu suivre ce qui est
sans doute son avion escorté par des
avions de chasse américain c'est un
voyage extraordinaire qui a fait le
Président zenenski c'est le premier
voyage à l'étranger ce que disait
rappelait ce sujet de Florent Rondeau
mais il a sans doute pris le train
blindé depuis Kiev jusqu'à la ville de
Le vive et ensuite en convoi et bien
regagner une base militaire polonaise et
donc effectivement son avion a décollé
il y a quelques heures il serait
au-dessus de l'Atlantique pour dans une
base militaire de Washington estimé en
fin de la après-midi heure française
tout cela qui correspond très bien aux
prises de parole à la conférence de
presse qui vont intervenir dans la
journée à Washington mais quand on
l'avait rencontré avec georgiès Beck il
y a au tout début de la guerre à Kef il
fallait déjà imaginer les conditions de
sécurité sur les forces spéciales qui
nous donnaient un point précis GPS dans
la ville de Kiev nous avons été baladés
plusieurs fois emmenés dans d'autres
voitures pour arriver totalement à
l'aveugle sans téléphone sans aucune
moyen de communication un rendez-vous
secret avec le président qui s'est
montré tel qu'on le voit c'est à dire
extrêmement affable et très très à
l'aise dans la communication mais
entouré résolument d'une sécurité
maximum puisque il est l'homme à abattre
effectivement et il est l'homme qui est
tient le destin encore une fois de cette
guerre qui donc a duré 300 jours ça
devait être trois jours je vous rappelle
de la part de Vladimir Poutine pour
cette opération militaire spéciale
lancée le 24 février dernier donc oui
c'est un moment un tournant extrêmement
important on a sans doute très rarement
vu
dans l'histoire contemporaine des des
conflits internationaux une telle
intensité avec cette grande symbolique
aujourd'hui majeure de se déplacement du
président zzinski vers son doute qui est
devenu sa base arrière c'est-à-dire
l'Allier américain et les Ukrainiens
attendaient énormément sur le fond
puisque il y a donc c'est fameux missile
patriotes qu'il devrait être confirmé
par les Américains une nouvelle
enveloppe militaire peut être aussi
humanitaire les Américains redoutent un
sursaut russe voir une nouvelle
offensive sur Kiev il faut quand même
écouter les Américains puisque rappelons
que ce sont eux les services de
renseignement militaires américains qui
annonçaient l'offensive du 24 février
auquel à laquelle personne ne ne ne
croyait il le savait ils sont bien
informés et là il est vrai que on parle
on parlerait du nouvel réserve fraîche
de 200000 hommes en Russie prête à en
découdre on parle du nouvel offensive et
ça on savait que ça allait arriver
puisqu'on savait que Vladimir Poutine
n'allait pas se retirer de cette grande
symbolique d'une offensive sur Kiev la
guerre et sans doute pour la prise de
Kiev qui est l'origine de l'âme russe
selon vladiverpoutine donc on redoute
une nouvelle offensive via comme celle a
été en 24 février le 24 février dernier
via la Biélorussie les derniers voyages
de Val d'annivers Poutine tentent à
crédité cette thèse donc une nouvelle
offensive vers janvier février quand on
va rentrer dans le l'hiver après c'est
les bouts et tout ce qui retarde un peu
les offensives en ce moment donc c'est
vrai que c'est un tournant extrêmement
important et du côté ukrainien on a
toujours un peu rejeté sur l'Occident et
même sur l'Allier américain une forme de
molles et une politique de l'aide et
donc c'est vrai que c'est ce voyage est
extrêmement important puisqu'on sait que
pour des raisons de politique interne
aux États-Unis début janvier tout va se
jouer et peut-être que l'appui américain
pourrait changer donc encore une fois
Vladimir volonymer zelinsky joue son
destin en grand communicant en homme de
courage il porte la voix ukrainienne aux
États-Unis et on peut s'attendre à cette
adresse au Congrès ce soir dans la
journée pardon aux États-Unis qu'il soit
extrêmement percutante comme il nous a
habitué à le faire discours et
déplacement à suivre bien sûr sur notre
antenne merci beaucoup Cyril